frankreichs präsident marco hd pandemie
für beendet erklärt vive la france in
frankreich gilt kaum noch eine krone
regel mit dem virus leben das ist die
maxime dort vor ort wer in diesen tagen
also von deutschland nach frankreich in
dem zug seien ja der wird ein
denkwürdiges spiel erleben denn bis zur
grenze was wir auf in frankreich dann
was geweckt man fragt sich ja schon ob
es in frankreich einen anderen corona
virus gibt als in deutschland
also es aber eigentlich nicht der fall
die franzosen haben sich nur einfach
dazu entschieden mit ihm zu leben es
gibt noch die empfehlung das sind groß
und schulgebäuden belüftet wird aber
ansonsten lebt es sich in frankreich vor
der pandemie und was besonders schön ist
was mich besonders freut die experten
zeigen anders erzählt zu lande wo wir
panik lauter bereits gelösten einsicht
als experten gerade aufgelöst wurde fand
sein langjähriger vorsitzender der immer
nur monologe der presse kritische worte
über die politik zitat natürlich
bedauere ich vieles sagte er in einem
radiointerview wir haben manchmal die
gesundheit über die menschlichkeit
gestellt